a very common type of problem we see in
exams is having an equilateral triangle
enclosed within a circle here we have
triangle ABC enclosed within this circle
triangle ABC is equilateral and the
circle passes through all the vertices
of this triangle the first concept we
need to understand here is about the
center of the figure the center o is the
center of the circle as well as the
triangle next let's talk about OB OB as
we can see is the radius of the circle
let's call it lowercase R but there's
something even more special about OB it
bisects angle ABC as all angles of an
equilateral triangle equals 60 degrees
these two will equal 30 degrees each
okay so OB is the radius and also
bisects angle ABC let each side of the
triangle be s units long now listen to
this very carefully in our exams we may
be given the side of the triangle and
asked to find the area of the circle or
we may be given the radius and asked to
find the perimeter of the triangle and
there are many other combinations and to
solve for anything the only thing we
really need to know is the relation
between the radius of the circle and the
side of the equilateral triangle that's
all to derive a relation between them
let's draw a perpendicular or D from the
center on to BC this perpendicular
bisector is a BD and DC both will equal
s by 2 units deriving a relation is
pretty simple now just look at triangle
OBD it's a special triangle a 30-60-90
triangle so the sides will be in the
ratio one is 2 root 3 is 2 2 OB is our
and BD is s by 2 using this
ratio we can now easily find the
relation between R and s the side
opposite 90 degrees is R we are
interested in the side opposite 60
degrees which is PD if two corresponds
to R then what will Route three
correspond to it will be R root three by
two so BD will be R root three by two
and we also know that BD is equal to s
by two there you go we have the relation
multiplying both sides by two we get s
as R root 3 this is like a super
important relation in a figure where a
circle passes through the three vertices
of an equilateral triangle its sides
will equal root three times the radius
let's look at a typical problem that we
may come across we are given that ABC is
equilateral and a circle passes through
all three vertices of this triangle we
are given the area of the circle as 16
pi and we are expected to find the
perimeter of the triangle ABC ok let's
think to find the perimeter we just need
the length of one side of the triangle
as it is equilateral now how do we get
the side we just looked at a relation
between the radius of the circle and the
site of this equilateral triangle so if
we are able to find the radius of the
circle we can easily find this side
which in turn will give us the perimeter
and guess what we have the area of the
circle and that will give us the radius
if we assume the radius to be R then we
can say that PI R squared will equal 16
pi solving this we get the value of R as
4 units the relation we had looked at
was s is equal to R root 3 so the length
of the side of the triangle will be 4
root 3 units as the triangle is
equilateral the perimeter will be thrice
the side
which is 12 root 3 units area of the
circle to its radius radius to the side
and side to the perimeter so with
respect to this figure remember a few
simple things if you are given any of
these you can find any of these if you
know the area of the circle you can find
the height of the triangle or if you
know the circumference of the circle you
can find the side of the triangle and
also if you are given any of these you
can find any of these trust me this is
interesting
you can even form your own example to
try it out make an equilateral triangle
form a circle around it and with any of
these given try finding out the others
and with any one of these given find the
others
you